ó
[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá votar é o tema da conferência por lá
é na produção estava indicado houve unir
e olympia snowe touch é eu estou com
sorte é essa visão
vou tentar uma forma muito sintética por
criar
queria desejar lutar por outros
objectivos fique também foi reajustado
em que não venham cá falar a tecnologia
não vem cá falar da etec
vou tentar transmitir sentimentos e
fundamental - sentidos e vou tentar
falar de habitantes
aí eu sou conceito que traz cá eu
gostava de partilhar da empresa em
falando na introdução do dolo na empresa
trabalhamos em conjunto em grupo e
gostamos muito dos inspirar em livros
corremos em filmes e concretamente para
a apresentação
há uma ascensão claro a música dos beats
ao amor love é também muito presente
se aqui nesta conferência
a palavra que eu posso já a synthes a
levo comigo já é nada é impossível é o
fato da equipe pessoas é tão
interessante podemos partilhar podemos
conversar
jutahy o grande conquista é para
podermos fazer algo mais do portugal
profundo e também a nossa forma de estar
é na nossa área de investigação e
desenvolvimento e conhece como a frase é
que todos conhecemos acho que temos que
aproveitar e usar aquilo que é bom na
pessoa
deus quer o homem sonha a obra nasce
vamos retirar três palavras desta frase
primeiramente inspiradoras para nós deus
no sentido ao excluir a no sentido de
nos dar cinco sentidos visão audição
tato o olfato
são cinco sentidos que nascem connosco
um sonho
eu acho que é
se vão ao recordar com manhã saem
ter o sonho para concretizar e nós
devemos ter temos que ter sonhos por
estar vivo e orçamento o trabalho da
obra
esta frase pode sintetizar e juntos em
quadra muito bem daquela que é a
realidade atual do multitouch
isso porque porque não há dúvida nenhuma
quanto nós que os sentidos que nós temos
estão subaproveitados nós nas nossas
rotinas diárias não estamos a usar o
ordenamento sentido é que diz como isto
na perspectiva do marketing
eu mexo lento afunilar uma oportunidade
e cultural e permite criar e realizar
muitos sonhos e hoje vou tentar passar
condições em que estava também
compartilhar aqui o trabalho àquela obra
já foi feito por muitas empresas por
muitos laboratórios no seixal é que o
trabalho está feito mas fundamentalmente
aquilo que pode ser feito e que podem
alimentar os sonhos de outras equipas de
outras empresas para podermos trabalhar
em comunidades já que estamos perto
central a minha vida se mostrar anos
tentava em 3 com sete chaves
op la roja free óptimo gravar e podemos
ganhar e fundamentalmente dos cinco
sentidos vão buscar um sentido do tac
para nós do tjes do multitouch o sonho o
sonho podemos rentabilizar o sentido o
tanto o mutantes no nosso dia a dia como
é que nós no nosso dia a dia a nossa
rotina diária do nosso fazer na nossa
vida podemos usar o tom o notice that is
como uma complementaridade da nossa
atuação em o fazer porque os sonhos têm
pôster o dia 30 fácil fazer o que foi
feito
estamos a fazer que vamos fazer o
prelado
optimizado
tanto o tanque é o incrível sentido sim
quizá bloco pela forma como os anti é no
período da gestação
o tato o primeiro sentido desenvolver
está dentro de nós desde a primeira fase
os dedos só uma das áreas mais sensíveis
do nosso corpo e uma coisa
impressionante
na ponta de cada vez nós temos cerca de
100 sensores de toque sai é uma coisa
impressionante
maria nós a usarmos apenas um dedo ficam
nove
quero dizer que nós oitavas apenas 10%
da capacidade do toque
esta é uma oportunidade bem
identificados por nós
várias empresas privadas as ligações
envolvimento necessário também ter noção
de comprimento do negócio é também um
grande negócio já é um grande negócio e
continuará a ser um grande negócio é bom
que seja para trazer empresas para
trazer mais planos para trazer mais
retorno para trazer mais desenvolvimento
nós precisamos e acreditamos que esta é
uma estratégia não falando muito em
números mas nos estados unidos há dois
grandes mercados e supermercados
representam cerca de 18 mil milhões
bilhões
quer na área da tecnologia de consumo
quer na área do do escarro a tecnologia
de consumo
falando só dos smartphones nós já
podemos incorporar a tecnologia de
tantos anos representam um número
acumulado até final de 2010 cerca de um
milhão de unidades vendidas apenas no
equipamento que usa tanto na componente
tanto temos também uma obsessão que é
muito relevante é que não só da
tecnologia mas também nas cinco rodadas
de
fugir à tecnologia como sendo os jogos o
tanque é muito usado na componente
didática
o trânsito aqui vou cuidar do negócio
também e complementar porque o
multitoque se está utilizando os dedos e
às vezes não temos essa noção porque o
ambiente não é propício que isso
aconteça os dedos têm uma alta definição
obviamente tivemos a interagir com o
website no computador o website foi foi
parceiro interage com o rap na nova
lógica se o conteúdo for feito para o
toca o dia de ontem uma alta resolução e
um espectro muito disse ele tem são da
espécie é que os dedos já são
equipamentos de série
nós temos que ao menos seja os pec temos
10 dash dedos o que é muito
nós temos equipados com dez dedos
cantarmos
é natural é natural no sentido que nós
na nossa rotina diária
já estamos usar os dedos
o morto antes para podermos interagindo
com que borges por exemplo e depois a
outra potencialidade que o que é
fabulosa e estava também compartilhar
quando falamos de malte tanto podemos
falar do mundo usa vários torcedores e
interagem com a mesma tecnologia e
podemos estar a falar do último censo
outros sentidos podem recuar
tirando proveito dessa capacidade outra
componente é componente de usar o
montante para grandes formatos de
interação e formato curvo o formato
surgiu é e geométricos cristo interagir
directamente sem aquele paradigma do
ecrã normal ou seja há uma grande
oportunidade
essa oportunidade está perfeitamente
sustentável do nosso ponto de vista e
não daquilo que está a ser feito via e é
um sonho um sonho que é complementar
porque o que nós acreditamos que é vaz
do multitoque e hoje o mercado já
conhece que a definição do multitoque
é uma forma de interagir em simultâneo
com três dedos ou mais numa superfície
toca julga que já várias pessoas tiveram
essa experiência e estava a aproveitar
este momento para perceber quem é que já
interagiu usando facebook tocam curioso
é que eu apontei é típica mas mostra que
há claramente um potencial enorme de
podermos por vince província esta
experiência e por outro lado a partir da
experiência para produtos e para
componentes mais concretos no dia a dia
quando o nosso então uma forma muito
resumida no nosso sonho é poder
transformar o interface que nós temos
atualmente tem uma interface com o
computador com a componente dos
smartphones que o grave
usa a interface no natural de usar o
inter faz quando se mistura claramente
aquilo que é digital e aqui pode ser é o
real em termos muito pragmáticos nós no
limite podemos alterar a cor do
automóvel se material usado no automóvel
estiver preparado pra isso fazendo uma
configuração da cor queremos alterar no
limite nós podemos prover esse tipo de
alteração e podemos fazer mais muito
mais
mas pra isso é importante jogar aqui no
meu completo que não posso deixar de
desperdiçar
precisamos de criar todo um conceito de
ecossistema ecossistema envolvendo
universidades centros de investigação e
empresas e trabalhar num sistema que
está estado por exemplo nos estados
unidos em silval é trabalharmos todos
para um bom conjunto e os mutantes
jutahy aqui uma componente agregadora
para podermos trabalhar de uma forma e
ao sistema
depois duas componentes fundamentais que
complementar
por um lado os conteúdos o multi touch
vai nos obrigar a repensar toda forma de
conteúdos de interface e por outro lado
as tecnologias não existe uma tecnologia
não existem duas tecnologias dos
montantes vão ter que existir várias
para se poderem adaptar não só usei cras
não só o teto não só ao chão não só as
correntes de porto ferreira e interagir
com o tudo no nosso universo toda a
nossa forma de atuação ou soja e para
terminar
temos a noção clara de que uma titan es
que minha para aquilo que será uma
interação natural por dia quase que
genéricas anpg ações gerações que vai me
seguir vamos trazer o tipo de relação da
equipe possuir um uso do toque do
multitoque dos conteúdos e devotamento
virtual eo real
esta é a nossa expressa mas pra isso
temos que reverter aquilo situação neste
momento porque a tecnológico
está demasiado voltado para apresentar
gadgets que às vezes não tem eu também
se dará nenhuma para quem
responsabilizar
nós temos que dar mais palavra às
pessoas aqui nessa terra inclusive do
mundo de tantas pessoas têm outro
palavrão tenha primeira palavra e devem
ter nossa perspectiva aquilo que são as
iluminações do povo vir a seguir e as
pessoas podem dar impulso de como é que
querem ver os erros ea via que tem
inclusive ajudando no seu vi havia de
poder ter mais proveitos mais interação
é com o top é esta a mensagem que estava
a passar e não clique em seus pés
nós temos cerca de mil reitores do tanto
nas nossas mãos
obrigado
[Aplausos]